okay so this is a Jake the dad we're
gonna interview all the puppies that's
like very half-assed Oprah that's my I
knew an excited woman that kind of
sounds like Oprah I know it's not
oppress on just cuz I'm too lazy to do a
good Oprah so yeah but uh
Rainicorn has puppies and this is just
the so Jake is not a dad and we see
these great designed puppies I mean I
just let each one look strange and has a
weird different power which is just not
what I was expecting I mean I guess I'm
the one hey you know you know they're
gonna start look like a combination but
you think they're all gonna kind of like
look the same or something I didn't
expect a mom they have any powers or
anything so okay I know in Adventure
Time logic that makes more sense but
still well okay you have Rainicorn
magical being
and Jake magical being how could you not
expect a puppy if it was Finn and a
magical being okay maybe there's a
fleshy layer teleporting I mean think of
her teleported or stuff like better but
now they have double magic G yeah no but
that I didn't expect excuse me not
knowing my adventure time scientific
occult no excuse I'm sorry that's the
best like you killed Phoebe
oh so this is pretty much just watching
Jake be a dad and him getting really
into it which actually is kind of
touching I mean it's not like okay I'm
gonna be a dad because it's awesome like
he seems to legitimately really care
about his kids and it'll lose sleep over
it he'll push himself too far and he'll
get over paranoid and just like obsess
over them and yeah it's just a really
really cute thing and then he's reading
this book I'm gonna look at him the
manual yeah yeah
mom's manual which is kind of like this
little computer game thing that's
supposed to give advice from his mother
and one of them was this book was it
called like baby-eating Fox eating
babies yeah he looks through and it's
like wow this is a lot darker than I
remember so he gets rid of the book a
bunch of foxes find it
I love these foxes I really want them to
come back they just made me laugh so
hard
uh and they're like oh this thing says
we shoot babies let's achieve babies
yeah what's in there just let you do it
yeah they just stand there let you do it
yeah okay so Jake is pushing himself too
hard and he tries to take them all off
for a walk and they all go and do stuff
to endanger themselves he freaks out
again over inserts himself and the Fox
is fine to think he's a baby not very
good baby but you know just got to take
what you got do you know I gotta jump in
yeah you gotta jump in guys now every
baby is going to be the perfect baby so
they go and try to eat them and then all
the puppies come and save them with
their magic powers
sort of like Voltron they'll begin to
form this giant puppy machine and use
their powers that's very funny and yeah
Jake realizes oh I got a let up and not
be so protective and it turns out they
grow up even faster Anita's like one of
them has a beard already and so Jake's
now back with the group that's the one
thing I I didn't know about cuz on the
one hand it's like okay yeah I want Jake
back with the group I wanted to you know
God the adventures and stuff but that
that kind of seemed like a cheat I'm
like okay well it's like all this
responsibility all the learning in just
a day I'm sort of like I don't know
there's something about that I don't
know how I would have worked around it
but it seems like for an episode to be
so dedicated to this and then just like
you know when teaching freaking lesson
they're like oh and the next day it's
fixed that that's the only thing I
wasn't quite sure about but okay you
know what it is it solved two problems
that like every 80s and 90s show head we
need to Eisen even say every eighties
and nineties every show at some point
times like
we need to have a baby on the show
that'll be awesome it happens on all of
them you know or okay we're gonna bring
a little cousin oliver to the brady
bunch yeah whatever they never saw them
every time they bring a child into it so
this way they bring in the babies
everyone's like oh baby
episodes over done got that out of the
way it looks like The Cosby Show with
Rudy but not bringing in Olivia exactly
I mean it's like I and like I said I
don't know the way around I'm not even
me this is the best way I mean don't get
me wrong it just seems like if you're
gonna dedicate yourself to giving Jake
such a likable the Serb connection with
these kids are giving him so paranoid
and sorry teaching this lesson you know
and so the Finding Nemo I said you know
you have to create distance sometimes
you know it's I don't know it's like cuz
I got my scores I've gotta be old enough
just to go to school now then it's like
he'd still be off not pea - I don't know
I always have to make that Disney
reference don't you but Al's Pixar and
according to you back when they were
still good actually Finding Nemo snow
when they're already bought up by Disney
I don't know did you like it no well
then obviously it's active era bugs like
- okay well great I try again um so yeah
I mean for me the big thing I really
really liked I liked it seemed Jake
really into the kids and I'd like to see
how paranoid he gets it's super
protective and uh I don't know it was a
nice change of pace but was still
believable and yeah I don't know I
really like that I serve like that that
connection you only see the father
screwing up with the cute old man and
kids they don't know what why see how
cliche all the time and it's uh I see
that changing I see more and more like
not just in real life the media - like
it's more like hey like a father any
with kids and they really have fun with
the kids like it's totally cool and they
genuinely like it - like it's you know
pull out your hair crazy but it's still
a nice experience and still love them
loving them it's not like whatever all
those 80s and early
I swear it's like a baby oh oh and yeah
I don't know this is a sublet mr. mr.
hands us breakers how did be preggers
just like okay um so yeah so I like I I
thought was a really nice suite up over
there I don't know what the hell
happened to me no more babies for you I
retired no it was really cute and I
agree with you it was really great to
see Jake doing everything he can and he
wasn't that he was this bumbling fool he
was just a really loving caring dad
overdoing it only because that's what
new parents do you're like oh my gosh oh
my gosh I just want everything perfect
and I thought that was really really
cool that's what made it for me cuz once
you get over there oh my god super cute
babies you gotta have something to the
episode and that's what I liked I really
enjoyed watching Jake which is really
weird
in probably the greatest world he's ever
had
I just as dad it was just so sweet you
got it and again it's a cartoon but like
you could really feel or I could really
feel and I could really see through Jake
like he just wants this to go right like
he really SuperDuper loves these babies
and and I when they drew the eyes and
he's tearing up like they're just the
beautiful babies um that was cool
uh I like that Finn was there but he
wasn't really it was kind of like well
here's Finn here you go but anyways with
BMO jumping a little white pink rabbit I
forgot about that that's really fun
in a way
when you do first have kids that's kind
of you drove away for everyone like
there's your best friend but you have
these babies and your best friends like
what else and you don't realize that
you're just you're just in your own
little world and that was kind of really
neat how that worked out the foxes oh my
god the foxes and those guys like
chewing the rock and there's like God
why haven't we babies borrow boxes boxes
this was really cool this was SuperDuper
cool I love I've been anticipating these
babies I wasn't I was it was everything
I dreamed of and then more because it
was cooler because I have no imagination
so this was so cool um I love that lady
was just kind of like whatever Jake
you're kind of going too far but
whatever I'll let you do your thing like
when she goes and looks at the window
and tells the kids like come on I don't
know something like paper you know go
help your dad out or whatever well first
off they were running around she calls
them all yeah and then it keeps getting
dragged away and she's like oh go help
your dad I like I like how she is she
just where Jake is very much learning
she just gets it immediately and she you
know and then she's rested too and stuff
like that that's a nursery I really like
I really like when he says you know
you're resting for both oh that was
really sweet and yeah and she just sort
has a better understanding of it um you
know I mean yeah like you know kids come
in and they just come in oh go save your
father and somebody knows what they're
capable of already um and yeah whether
it's just knowing maybe she knows other
rainicorns have done it with dogs I
don't know she has sleep and she's
thinking clearly because she's been
sleeping no good resting I mean well you
can also look at it from the other
perspective of well it's mother's
instinct yeah that's a common cliche
where the mom knows what to do because
it's just a mother's instinct and
there's definitely there's
we bad mothers I mean I'm not even seen
that's what they were going for this
with this but that could easily be one
way to interpret it but I agree maybe
it's just cuz she had some sleep and had
time to process things your perspective
is different when you're tired I mean
yeah baby that's one of my favorite
parts is where he's making breakfast
poke kind of like a dead person not
maybe because I remember when our
daughter was younger and all that stuff
in the beginning I always kind of
thinking to make sure she's breathing
and she's okay well some of our family
friends decided to tell the stories like
oh yeah
my friend had a kid who was sleeping on
the couch realm rolled off the couch and
dies wow that's a new parent of course I
was terrified my daughter was gonna die
take note never tell horror stories to
new parents honestly that's like the one
thing like I'm obviously not a dad but
that's the one thing I'm always the most
afraid of I'm afraid that my paranoia is
going to I am gonna be I'm just gonna
freak out that everything but what I
always hear is that even if you are
someone that freaks out about the stuff
it's like the stuff that you actually
get freaked out over is not the stuff
you think it is oh yeah it's like yeah
it's like stuff that's like I don't know
it's like it is hair-pulling and it is
very loving too but it's never the stuff
you think it's gonna be it's always
something you never expected so it's
like I just let go okay just find out
when it happens for me I was definitely
paranoid in the beginning but after a
good month I kind of smoothed into yeah
yeah it was the cutest daddy ever better
than Jake know one thing that you guys
didn't bring up well that I guess maybe
it's just my favorite it's finished
shirt I love that shirt
like that yeah if anyone in the comment
section can tell me where I could buy
one of those I would be very grateful
thank you how difficult would that be
get a blue shirt no oh I completely
forgot last one I need to make a shout
out to some of the people in the
comments not by names I don't know any
of them up and see yeah you got the
milkshake reference correct I love all
of you kisses do I know what the the two
things that I want bring up before
before wrapping up here one is that well
know what we'll get to hear subdued but
you know you're just the other stuff the
two things that really well know the to
me the two things that really stick out
to me is that well what what you were
saying about like you know mother's
instinct and stuff like that I know it's
like you said the cliche and stuff like
that but at the same time I do think you
know if a person is growing inside of
you and is your body for several months
how is it not possible to have a
connection somehow some sort of instinct
you know just something you know or
imprinting or whatever they call it so I
think even though like I said there's
definitely bad lawyers you know it but
at the same time it's like when people
say no there is this connection there's
this instinct it's like I almost I'm
sorry like yeah how can there not be
when it's like it's not like oh it's a
part of me like symbolic no it is
literally a part of you for like several
months so lops off your finger and
throws it somewhere it's not like you're
gonna have some second action behind it
try this that's right get a nice alright
brightness go look at it how old are you
duh average he's old I'm you know say
you're in your 20s so you have been
living with your foot for 20 minutes if
I locked up your foot and drove off with
it somewhere
about your own admission in a sense you
should be able to find it by some
connection no but I've been growing on
you however what do people say when they
lose a limb or a foot or something like
that they say it's a limping it feels
like it's no there yeah but it's not no
no but it feels like it's still better
her to bother go oh I feel my baby's
still inside me it's not that I've been
gaining weight it's just I have phantom
pregnancies would you say phantom
pregnancy is a thing but yeah like that
we can't be no we weren't armed on that
but there you go
um the other thing I really really liked
like you know whatever it look at the
babies we think you did stuff the one I
don't know why the one moment I was
really like oh is when he was making
breakfast and it's totally quiet
there's mothers they had to do it and
it's just it's really dark nobody's
awake he's turning the volume down it's
a very quiet moment and just a little
bit of quiet again it just makes it seem
a little bit more real and a little any
foreign and strangers show this is but
but it makes the environment seem a
little bit more you see like you know
this takes that he's really devoting
time to doing this he's trying to get it
right he's trying not to wake anything
it shows that dedication which I really
like and that seemed like the most I
guess relatable for the moment because
you know because the of the volume is
down and he's trying to be quiet a to
listening to something you know we've
all tried to do something at some point
you know not to wake people up or to you
know whatever sniper test whatever not
to wake people up and watch something
yeah so we can relate to that very much
or I like you know it's so cool that
he's doing that so yeah that's that's
all I gotta say well I really like to
that's nice scene what I like to find it
by comparison to a lot of other shows is
and in most shows like lipstick he was
doing this stuff he was like put it down
and be boom like cuz he always
emphasized when you're trying to be
quiet like how the tiniest sound will
make this big huge thing which you know
sometimes it kind of does but I love how
it doesn't do that
this it's more the whole like oh it's
not you don't here tick-tick-tick
tick-tick-tick
you know or anything like that or the
cracking of the egg wasn't boom it was
just no he was just like like it was
more real than the over-exaggerated
times I'm doin in cartoons yes where
it's like yeah you kind of feel that way
when you're trying to be quiet but
that's not the way it is that's my great
for the Foley people too it's like oh
you guys don't need a voice for the
volume going down as sound boy thank you
yeah oh wait the do you remember
where he's from I want to say I saw him
before cuz I saw it I'm like I swear
like I don't remember where though I
mean I'm sure it's a previous episode
but when Jake is sick if it needs to
define the story he forces the duck in
that's right that's right
I do remember that there's no I don't
know actually the same Fox the voice is
the same I was gonna say if it's if it's
the same voice it's I'm guessing but I'm
just saying yeah that was great it was
okay I'm not I will go on record and say
I find babies ugly as hell I have always
think jr. was not an especially good
looking kid one that looks like half
pickle yeah but you know I on the other
hand cuz that first sounds like well
that's a weird thing to do but also like
a but not all kids are born you know to
be super good-looking you not
necessarily it's like you know killed
right and that she's only one that talks
and like honestly had a personality out
of it it's like whatever no I thought
they'd be cycling ever since I can
remember and yes when my daughter was
born I was like oh my god this baby so
true so it's not just all some like oh I
have a baby I love my baby no one else
no all babies yeah he's always been a
jerk
I will accept anything else
oh I really liked when Jacob was opening
the drawers with his ass you said that
so lovingly
Oh hurts previews I could open drawers
with my ass no I don't that's a lie
right I have a person with a pencil
mustache papers a pen must excuse me and
somebody wishing they could open toys
with their ass this is your life sir and
it hurts you knowingly come here yeah
yes go open some drawers with my ass
sweet oh that's ass told you man my wife
has skills